i'm mack walters i'm melanie faulkner my
name is brennan holmes
[Music]
i think i started at bioware back in
about the year 2000
i worked in gameplay programming ai sort
of a creature designer
kind of all over the place i started
when mass effect 3 was
just kind of starting full production
i've been at bioware now
almost 18 years and was a writer and
lead writer
on the entire trilogy as well back in
the day
do you remember what it was like playing
through the suicide mission
as it currently stands for the first
time i do uh
that was um another late night session
the whole structure of mass effect 2 is
dirty dozen right and so you have the
suicide mission very early on you know
you're going into a suicide mission but
i don't think people really understood
what that meant until they played it
like suicide missions sure impossible
odds yeah we got it
we'll just go in we'll do our thing
everyone will come out it'll be great
but um depending on how you play it you
can literally massacre
everyone it's a feeling of
responsibility it's the whole
spider-man thing where you just the
great power you become the shepherd and
all of a sudden you have this
responsibility for your squad
i think it was just all part of that
holy crap moment that i've done this
it that fed into it you are you are
responsible for this mission
you have to make all these little life
or death choices for every character and
you have no idea how they're going to
play out maybe
tally does die in those vents or maybe
you pick the wrong
the wrong leader for this sequence or i
think it's just looking at sort of the
impact that had on the community to this
day so
there's been guides written there's the
massive like standard flow chart that
people look at now like
for walking through that i still
reference that when i go back for my
playthroughs because i can't remember
all the various things for that i know
preston had one of those that he kept
hidden he didn't show too many people
i never saw the flow chart you have to
have that all documented somewhere
because there are just so
many decisions and branches and it's
it's incredible
like it was a slightly different
structure than we'd normally do this one
was definitely a lot
more open and that you could go and
recruit anyone you want and then the
loyalty missions were kind of there or
not and kind of optional and if you
wanted to kind of just rush right to the
end you could
because like that only works if you're
attached to those characters if you care
about them
if you don't really care about them then
it doesn't really have a lot of impact
you don't care about sacrificing so and
so it's tricky to make sure that people
had enough time to really live with
these characters especially with such a
large cast
need to make sure that they all have
enough time to breathe and really kind
of
you can get attached to them and
invariably care about whether they live
or die
i remember us having conversations
around like we'd see kind of a mock-up
and be like uh
that's not really a like a heroic death
you know there's
not enough time or they you know we
didn't have enough time to actually
even in the structure of the mission to
kind of
give every one of those sequences sort
of the same weight
because also it has to keep moving right
i think the most ignoble one i think is
the the doorway one where the doors are
closing and someone's looking out they
just get shot in the head and then
they're dead
i lost so many people the first time
because it wasn't as
clear as it is now i think we've cleared
it up a little bit more so
i made some bad choices yeah not a lot
of people made it through
so i remember actually playing it over
and over and over and over that night
trying to get different outcomes
and making just lots and lots of bad
choices i had a little spreadsheet
actually where i was starting to
to go through and try every possibility
then i just ended up asking preston the
next day it's like how the hell do you
how do you do this everyone keeps dying
we were just in development doing things
the way we normally do them
and then you know there's kind of this
rumor mill going through
the offices of oh have you seen charge
have you seen charge have you seen it
that was one of the challenges that i
took on
at the end of sort of mid mass effect 2
because i expressed an interest in
moving to design
so christina norman the lead gameplay
designer said okay well make a power for
this class and make it interesting it
was
game devs doing what game devs do which
is experimenting and trying something
cool
the vanguard's coolest power is
definitely biotic charge
and only vanguards get this power it
started as a sliding elbow to the face
kind of thing where you'd slide across
the ground and it felt
just terrible then we did a whole bunch
of different iterations and worked on
like the time dilation
and the timing and everything it
completely broke all the levels
because the player literally is
teleporting all over the place and
level designers don't like it when the
player is just suddenly across the map
so we had to come up with all sorts of
really interesting ways of solving that
and we had some conversations even about
cutting it we just kept pointing to it
and saying look
it's so much fun it's so much fun
it was interesting because when i saw it
i was just like you know oh my god how
do i do that just tell me how to do it
it wasn't unanimous
reaction like that across the board
because some people were concerned about
how that impacted the lord it's like
well how does that fit like what are we
a magic game now that you can just kind
of phase through things and do stuff i
think the writers were getting a little
pissed off because
because this was also on the heels of
the ammo stuff as well
so we had introduced ammo and we're kind
of like hey can you guys help us come up
with a story solution for this like a
lore sensitive thing and
they're kind of like okay and so they
went off and thought about it a bunch
and came up with a bunch of stuff for
that and then we came back again later
and we're like
so can people teleport in mass effect
no okay but what if they did yeah we had
these long conversations about how it
would make sense within the lore
because again it's really fun and so uh
they ended up coming up with some ideas
for
for kind of how to make it work but um i
think we stressed some people out and
then that became the fun challenge of
kind of like okay well we probably can't
explain it through mass effect fields
and
what's going on so how do we do that and
of course so then you're kind of
in a way reverse engineering the lore
around it but
you have to be um you know flexible and
open to doing that because
you know you never know where a great
idea is going to come from
and at the same time when you see
something that's just like game changing
and going to be a ton of fun you're like
you've got to find a way to make it work
you know we were moving more towards
the action side of the action rpg at
that point right so
it just this to me felt like something i
hadn't done in any game before
and to be able to do it in in there was
just like well this is amazing we have
to do this
we found something cool we found a way
to make it work if we find something
else cool we'll find a way to make that
work
right
the geth quarry in conflict it's it's
one of the central conflicts for the
whole trilogy
and it's sort of the backdrop against
which a lot of the
the first two games play out before you
see the resolution the third it's kind
of just always there
i think just really seeing the the
conclusion of that it's been building
for that entire trilogy but that's just
a hugely impactful moment for me
um tally's tally's kind of big
moment and mass 3 was a really big
deal as a dev because that was right
when i was first starting
and i was in localization but i was
lucky to be invited to a cinematic
review at the time i can remember the
leads review where we
looked at it i in this particular one um
we were looking at sort of
bad outcomes the level designer was kind
of driving through and making choices to
sacrifice the quarians and
tally is she's she's kind of begging
like please don't do this please no
it was a white box review so there was
no art there was
nothing in it um and just
the emotional impact it had
without anything in it it just made me
realize
how how powerful the story of this whole
trilogy is and just how consuming it is
and how
amazing it is even with with nothing
else there like it just kind of was
all the world coming to me in that one
moment like holy this is amazing how we
do this
and then there's that that one moment
where tally falls off the cliff
and shepard kind of runs up and dives to
grab her hand and there's
there's a pause i didn't know what was
gonna happen it was
just the iconic falling back and that
was i don't know if i want to call it a
beautiful moment but just that it was
such an
impactful moment shepard's hand is off
screen and you can't quite see you don't
know if he's caught or not and there's a
sort of moment of hope
and then it pans back and his hand's
empty and
yeah the room was just like oh no
i teared up i had a very emotional
moment
even with um that bass level white box
scene so i just yeah it was it was
emotional
even even at his bare bones that hit
pretty hard
you know and we were working on it too
so
there's a layer of insulation but still
like um
yeah that that sucked
the way the conflict was always framed
is legion and tally were supposed to be
sort of the
analogues for the larger conflict and
the two and so having to make that
choice between the two
was kind of always the intent especially
if you've
worked with them to kind of overcome
some of their differences throughout
that
that sort of betrayal and legion's
constantly you know asking if this unit
has a soul and
it was still very early on in my career
so everything was still
very magical in how it played out in
game that scene
i think just it it was so powerful and
it was so early on for me it was just
playing it as a player too yeah
it was as emotional as when i first saw
it in the white box i definitely didn't
understand
in general actually um just kind of how
much these characters would end up
meaning to people
you know it's only been through a lot of
the fan interaction after the game and
really seeing like
how much people love these characters
and stuff but i think it's really been
that that message has really been driven
home right
so i think yeah at the time we knew it
would be impactful but not maybe this
impactful
it's a little bit like the tally moment
for me and mass effect 3 was
my first uh mass effect game on the dev
side
and just a yeah a child like everything
so fragile um and then climbing into
that
ship and just how delicately
it was animated and he just he seemed so
real
and you know kind of struggling to get
in there like a kid would
and it just summed everything up almost
in that one
motion it just kind of captured
everything for me as far as the emotion
goes it's just so
heartbreaking oh it we have such amazing
animators and that animation was just
done so well
and the moment it just that whole scene
how it plays
out
[Music]
mass effect is a lot of moments for me
it's a lot of the little details that
make it special and
that moment i feel just kind of
summarized everything that you're
fighting for in that you know
five seconds or whatever it was
[Music]
for us we knew this was sort of wrapping
up shepard's story and there's so many
goodbyes in that
in that final few hours of the game
right and to me
you know anderson had been one of those
characters who had just supported
shepard all the way through no matter
what was always there for you
and really kind of represented that
father figure
we did it
yes we did
it's quite a view
creating it in such a way that you know
a military person
could sort of finally break down and
just say look i'm proud of you and and
say it like they mean it to
someone they really care about right you
did good child
you did good
i'm proud of you
[Music]
thank you sir
the series is wrapping up so all these
experiences we were having
as a team but also with people like jen
hale and anki david and the actors and
everything
this was all kind of coming to an end as
well
so it was kind of also describing the
end of our journey at least as that
group right
and i just remember a lot of tears in
the session and and um
you know just the emotional impact of it
carrying forward and like i said when i
watch it to this day i'm still like
i tear up i think well that's that's a
good scene i don't say that to
to to my own horn or anything it's just
it has the impact
that i'd hoped it would and everyone who
worked on it from
you know the the actors to the animators
the people lighting the scene you know
just really
you know helped capture everything that
that was i was trying to do and so it
was just
it's just really special for that you
know recording it
with uh keith david and then with uh i
certainly remember the session with jen
hale and
we were doing it remote at the time but
you know we could see each other and
hear each other and everything like that
for me at least as a writer until i hear
the words
that's a big component of it i can
always imagine the visual
um but imagining the performance that
you're going to get from the actor is
harder
so you just want to leave that to them
and see what they come back with and
that's where so much of the magic
happens
right like you put out words and they
come back to you in a way that
is nuanced in a way that you weren't
expecting you ever wonder
how things would have been different how
our lives would be
different if this hadn't happened it was
great just sort of hearing it all come
together and
we always record separately of course
right like we don't have multiple actors
in the booth we have one actor at a time
so you're always trying to imagine half
of the conversation
in your head right at a time so i think
then you finally
see it all come together in the game
when thinking about my favorite mass
effect moments it does kind of play out
like a montage and i don't know if
that's
all of the 80s movies i watched growing
up but shepherd dancing is
in that montage probably in more than
one place
again i think it's just the the little
details that go into mass effect that
make
it such a a rich world this very serious
space soldier just taking a moment you
know for a little dance break i just i
love that
a lot of my favorite characters over my
decades of watching movies and playing
games and
reading they're the human ones the ones
who
you see make mistakes or that they're
not quite perfect
and in shepherd you're not perfect
you're making these decisions and you
you don't
get everything that you want and yeah
just he's not a great dancer either
so it just rounds him out nicely
thank you all for your loyalty and
support like i've been working on mass
effect for
i think with legendary edition it'll be
like 10 years right
a lot of these characters and these
it's kind of like an gamepl friend in a
lot of ways it's been very nostalgic
coming back and kind of just seeing all
this old stuff
kind of working with it again and trying
to polish it up and
bring it forward a bit the game itself
is
is one thing like how that changed me as
a player and just how that opened me up
to just just so many different games but
it's more on the
the working side of it and just the the
team
and the people that i have met creating
mass effect and getting to be part of
the franchise
i i can't describe
how lucky i feel just the passion that's
there
and just this incredible group of people
when
i started mass effect you know i had
a game under my belt but it was the
first game that i had
straight empire and the first one i had
done as a writer you know the the
biggest thing
that i kind of took away from the whole
mass effect experience is the
camaraderie
and it's mirrored in obviously the game
you know choosing your squad and
these are the people you're going to go
to war with you're going to go through
hell together
and that experience working on teams
that have been phenomenal is is uh
you know the best memories i have right
period especially revisiting now with
the legendary edition it's really kind
of
um reinforced that opinion that like
just the thing that i really like
helping to create
are games that that matter to people
that make them feel things
that they can have emotional attachments
and connections to not necessarily just
you know something we punched in one of
the face a lot or something i have a
very
varied background career-wise until i
came into games
and i feel like i was just sort of
looking for the right thing that fit
when i found games i found my home but
just
part of that was bioware and the people
there and the the mass effect team
i just yeah the people on it they
they've made they've made my life i've
stayed there for you know over a decade
now and they're such a huge part of my
world
the legendary edition specifically
coming back to it you know we had this
sort of
smaller team at the start and we were a
bit scrappier
people wearing multiple hats kind of
like we did in the old days development
that wasn't quite so compartmentalized
and it's been
like just such a pleasure to go back to
that kind of development and
and be able to work with a team like
that again and you don't take for
granted the people around you
right when you're when you're working on
these things nobody can do this stuff on
their own
it's it is a 100 team effort and you
have to really
uh trust and respect the people that you
work with and and
yeah i mean i would certainly say that's
probably the the biggest thing that i've
learned throughout the the course of the
trilogy and
now on to the legendary
[Music]
you